on the mound tonight for the pittsburgh
pirates rookie 23 year old right-hander
miguel yahoo ray is making a second
start of his big league career
uh it's pretty well on his last retired
the 11 of the first 13 batters but then
ran into some trouble in the fifth
inning mike talkman will stand in got in
on his hands popped it up third base way
defoe is there
and in foul ground he makes a catch for
the first out there's that cutter mike
ustremski hit her now swing and a miss
and he strikes out yastremski the throw
to first completes it
that's the second out and buster posey
will bat with the bases empty swinging a
soft lighter out to left into that
sunfield tom is there to squeeze it and
the giants are gone in order one two
three on the bump for the giants tonight
kevin gausman their ace
going his eighth start of the season
he's 3-0 with a 1-9-7 45 and two-thirds
innings pitched more than a strike got
an inning only 12 walks left these
righties as you can see very very
difficult to hit no matter what side of
the plate that you're hitting from adam
frazier swings at the first pitch from
gausman and pops it up shallow left
field crawford going back from short
underneath it and he makes a catch
i think gosmen will take that one pitch
one out the shortstop kevin newman
here's a swing and a chopper to short
crawford's got it he'll throw to first
in plenty of time to get newman who does
have pretty good speed that is out
number two two down for brian reynolds
reynolds pulls one sharply but right to
first belt playing behind the bag has it
he's gonna race to first base and he'll
get there ahead of reynolds gausman
retires the side in order granted belt
will start it off for san francisco that
one is down and in ball four so belt
draws the walk that's the first base
runner for the giants in this game
avalonia comes up now strike three call
and tom hallian i'm just my favorite
with that demonstrative strike three
looking call so the veteran is out one
away brandon crawford crawford swings
and hits it right to the second baseman
fraser on the short one relay
two a double play at four six three
double play ends the inning the cleanup
hitter will craig to lead things off
guasman's one-two pitch is swung on and
missed strike three splitter got him
that's the first
kevin gausman strikeout here's a
fastball strike three called on the
outside corner polanco disagreed but
that
is out number two two down back-to-back
strikeouts
1-0 pitch
that one's popped up by kai tom six up
six down for the pirates to start
against gaussman wilmer flores leading
off for the giants in the third inning
czech swing and craig is going to try to
track that down what a nice bobbling
catch over the shoulder no reason to get
fancy with it like he did but he made a
nice catch here's duggar to strike three
call right on the outer edge his command
is really good yahoo two down
and up comes gausman it's a swing and a
ball hit right back up the middle into
center field base hit
kevin gausman has started to swing the
bat a little bit it's a two-out single
for the pitcher
and who knows
maybe mike talkman can run into one and
that turns into something big for the
giants swinging the liner got a guy
there yeah defo right in position and
that ends the inning it'll be the top of
the order adam frazier to face kevin
gausman not up nine down for guzman thus
far two one is lined into right in a
base hit first hit for the pirates first
base runner for the pirates and now the
lead off man aboard in front of newman
lines that one duggar is going to make a
diving catch nice play steven duggar
wow that guy can play a center field huh
that was dead hit written all over it
off the bat that'll bring up brian
reynolds reynolds goes down swinging he
actually tipped a piece of it but posey
held on strike three gosling's fifth
strikeout of the game struck him out
with the splitter he threw a great one
there so two more strikeouts for
gaussman well i think we're all still
waiting for wilmer flores to get it
going i mean look at that batting
average it's down to 189. swinging the
base flores down on strikes miguel
yahuray has given up one hit through
five scoreless innings gregory polanco
for the pirates against kevin gausman
who's been great again
what else is new polanco grounds one
toward third and past the drawn in
longoria it trickles into left field
polanco going to second throws off line
he has a hustle double
how did that ball turn into a double the
shift taketh
and that might be the worst hit double
in the history of the game the first
runner in scoring position got him with
the splitter just nasty that guy knows
how to pitch seven strikeouts two two
fastball struck him out right into the
mid of posey two down oh two
he got the splitter and gosmen struck
him out too nasty bottom of the six
kevin gausman's been great but so has
the pirates pitching ben gamble strikes
out swinging that's four strikeouts in a
row in number 10 in the game
1-2 in the dirt with the splitter he
went around that strike three tom
alliance says posey gets the put out at
first and kevin gausman strikes out
reynolds for his 11th strikeout brandon
crawford for the giants in the eighth
inning giants still have not had a
runner at second base in this game a
fastball is hit high in the air to right
field and pretty deep polanco is back at
the wall it is
gone
a home run for brandon crawford just
over that 21 foot high wall and that's
the first run of the game it's one to
nothing kevin gausman is going to take
his time warming up for the bottom of
the eighth as he stays in the game swung
on and missed strike three and it was a
great splitter
for a career-high 12th strikeout for
kevin gausman two down and it'll be troy
stokes who hits he's grounded to the
right side belt playing way off the line
has it flips underhand style to guzman
who races to the bag and gets there
ahead of stokes for out number three
eight beautiful innings pitched by kevin
gausman tonight bottom of the ninth
inning in pittsburgh very exciting night
for kevin gausman let's see if he can
finish it off
so a couple little bloops and the
pirates are set up here in the ninth
inning first and third and still nobody
out that's gonna do it for kevin gausman
great outing by kevin jake mcgee will
come in to pitch and try to get the
giants through brian reynolds the former
giants minor leaguer who's turned
himself into the best pirates player
is coming up here through the right side
base hit pirates have tied the game
brian reynolds ties the game
with the single to right now the giants
are 90 feet away from taking a lead
crawford at third one out and austin
slater's got a chance hits this one a
little bloop into right field it's gonna
get down for a hit and that will put the
giants ahead two to one giants it's adam
frazier three hits in four at bats
stands in against berger swinging a fly
ball out to right
toward the wall and off oh off the glove
off the glove
falls down here comes perez he's in to
score
fraser's at third with nobody out a game
tying triple the fourth hit of the night
for adam frazier two intentional walks
bases loaded one out polanco is oh for
19 against lefties this year swinging a
fly ball hit deeply enough to center
this will score frazier and the pirates
walk off winners on the sacrifice fly by
gregory poloko